[musique]
difficile oui quand l'anxiété laisse faire
se produit également pendant les représentations lorsque
interrompu et la performance tous les spectateurs
les artistes des abris anti-bombes à l'heure actuelle devraient
se prélasser en quelque sorte toute cette période si
donner peut durer 40 minutes peut
durer une heure puis après
l'anxiété être immédiatement en mesure de
continuer la performance est très
épuisant et ça suffit comme ça
disons une sérieuse épreuve de force
généralement pour tout le monde
[musique]
en principe, chaque voyage auquel je pense
frontière qui pour nous porte maintenant
une grande valeur
parce que nous n'avons aucun droit à l'étranger
y représenter la culture ou le sport
quelques
oh bas nous devons toujours être
maintenant mon avis personnel est au top
[musique]